- [Kelly] Let's close the show out
with something positive from the internet.
This is what I'm liking.
(energetic music)
- Most high school seniors
are a few months from graduation
but in Pennsylvania,
a nine year old has them all beat.
This is David,
who just received his
high school diploma. What?
The aspiring astrophysicist
took online classes
during the pandemic and
graduated with a 4.27 GPA.
(crowd clapping and cheering)
He's also in Mensa. Sure.
Let's get this amazing kid in here,
everybody say hello to
David and his mama, Ronya,
watching on WGALA.
What's up y'all?
How ya doing?
- We're doing well, how are you?
- You're doing better than well, ma'am.
Y'all are killing it in your household.
So David, congratulations
on finishing high school.
Is it true that you didn't think
this was like a big deal?
- Yeah, me and my mom had a back and forth
and I'm like, okay, I
graduated. That's very nice.
"You graduated at the age of
nine. This is incredible."
And so I finished elementary
school in half a year,
I finished middle school in one year,
and then I finished
high school in one year.
And so she, and so she has to explain
to me about how, okay, you
graduated at the age of nine,
look at how you finished the
grades like in two months.
- I'm just telling you right
now, you are exceptional.
That is not a, normally
I mean I have a six and
eight year old, David.
They're not on the same
path is all I'm saying,
Like most aren't.
And Ronya, this is, this is
something you felt you had to do. Why?
- I needed to challenge my son.
He's a gift from God and I felt
that I have to give him
the best that I got.
So I had to do a lot of research.
I had to look into things, I had to learn
I had to get outside of the box
to challenge my child the way he deserves.
- Do you, did you, okay 'cause look,
I do homework with
like, my kids sometimes.
And I, I, and I used to have
other kids in my household too,
and so there would be older homework
and I'd be like Google
'cause I forgot, like
were you ever doing work
with him and going, I
don't know. Like, (laughs)
- Yes, there have been times,
- Oh my gosh, I love-
- that's happened, I
had to go to his father
'cause he's the guru, in certain things.
We split the subjects.
He has certain subjects that he's good at
like English and Finances.
I have Math and Science.
- Oh my god, you're like my sister.
She's the same way with
that kind of stuff.
I love that David was gonna out you,
he was like, yeah, no,
she got lost a few times like,
but thank you so much
David and thank you Ronya,
exceptional family y'all,
I'm liking your post right now, right.
(bell chimes)
- [Ronya] Thank you.
- And that's not all,
our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of Frixion, the go-to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate people going
after big dreams just like you.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars,
how's that sound?
- Wow. Amazing. Thank you very much.
- Aw, like look at his face! (laughing)
Good luck David,
you're gonna kill it in life!
You're already doin' it!
Thank you to all our guests this hour:
Jane Lynch, Bozoma Saint John,
Kevin Jonas, and Rachel.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not, try and change it.